[Música]
é esse homem de 48 anos meu pai dele
há dois anos ele volta hoje é mais
bacana
a gente consegue imaginar
só que ele era conseguem ver que a
entrada de andré ainda notas dela onde
hoje a chegar até o processo quando ela
chega a oito
ela é uma memória sobre a cidade de
braga
vocês conseguem ver o que está
acontecendo lá atrás dos portugueses é
uma coisa estranha e coloração e braga
ele não só coloca o seu estudo do início
do século 20 até hoje
é o enem já sólida que esse quadro não
era de que ele não era de madeira e
palha
dessa maneira a cidade grandiosa
exatamente um colégio em 2006
a cena do cotidiano belém contratado
pelo são paulo onde a falta de água
também curiosamente pedir que as pessoas
levassem pouco de suas casas e espaços
públicos
os mapas marca o tamanho deveria ser a
primeira lembrança da história as
pessoas com essa história através da
memória na copa de 2006
as ações do pac palavra
[Aplausos]